c'est un rendez vous attendu de pied
ferme par le personnel soignant à
l'hôpital public
après dix semaines d'une crise sanitaire
sans précédent le gouvernement sait
qu'il joue son va tout avec ce ségur de
la santé les réponses seront à la
hauteur des attentes assure olivier
ferrand encore une fois je connais les
impatiences je sais qu'elles sont déjà
anciennes
je le dis nous irons vite nous irons
fort parce que si les leçons de la crise
sanitaire doivent être retirés
rien ne vaut l'expérience vécue et les
soignants savent ce qu'ils veulent ce
que veulent les soignants justement
c'est une hausse des salaires une
réorganisation du temps de travail et de
la gouvernance des hôpitaux
autant de chantiers qui seront au menu
des discussions un échange par
visioconférence auquel devraient
participer près de 300 personnes parmi
lesquelles des représentants des
hôpitaux mais aussi des et palais des
établissements médico sociaux
bref des gens qui savent affirme le
ministre de la santé
j'engagerai une concertation avec les
acteurs du système de santé pour qu'ils
puissent partager leurs expériences
partager leur vision du système de santé
ce qu'il faut améliorer ce qu'il faut
conserver ce qu'il faut revoir ce qu'il
faut simplifier ce qu'il faut ou mieux
valoriser olivier ferrand et l'ensemble
du gouvernement seront attendus au
tournant sur ce dossier car la tente est
grande
la semaine dernière une manifestation
réunissait des centaines de personnes à
paris avec un mot d'ordre sauver
l'hôpital public c'est le moment ou
jamais je pense
ça nous passons tous à tous mes
collègues mais c'est important
mettez souvent c est donc un peu plus
son vélo naturellement des effectifs les
salaires et puis travailler dans de
travailler dans de bonnes conditions
vous me voyez avec le masque aujourd'hui
ça a pris des semaines avant qu'on ait
des masques et aujourd'hui on entend des
politiques dire il n'y avait jamais
rupture de stock de masques
c'est quelque chose qui minent la
confiance que peuvent avoir les
professionnels de terrain pour mener des
négociations avec les politiques
les discussions qui démarrent ce lundi
seront coordonnées par l'ex secrétaire
générale de la cfdt nicole notât
elles doivent durer sept semaines